guys do you hear it yes it's a new
episode of Castle Rock and this might be
one of the most revealing yet so let's
get into it it looks like the show is
heading into autumn and judging by its
10 month production schedule we'll
probably see episode ten take place in
or around winter the picturesque scenery
is accompanied by the familiar sound of
the woods we've been hearing since
episode 1
Matthew Devers casket which suffered
from exploding casket syndrome and
episode 5 is lowered into the ground at
his memorial only the pastor and Henry
are there even though multiple chairs
and programs have been arranged
pastor recites the same line from
Corinthians that Mathew Deaver recounted
tamale in episode 3 while Henry
continues to be afflicted by the ringing
in his ear the kid is seen for the first
time since Allen put a gun to his head
looks like he's going to enlist his help
after all
the kid puts on Matthew Devers clothes
and finds several letters and sermon
tapes could these letters be from Odin
branch who we'll meet later on in the
episode the kid watches old VHS tapes
just like the one Henry burned in
episode 3 they depict young Henry
walking through the woods and what
appears to be the excursions his father
would bring him on back at the ceremony
we see the two creepy dudes from episode
5 next to an RV we'll meet them a bit
later
Allen meets with the kid who has told
him to pick up something in Syracuse
stating he must do it quickly because
time is Ruth's enemy is it because ruse
memory which she is slowly losing holds
the key the kid puts on the Walker
brothers The Sun ain't gonna shine
anymore on an identical vinyl player
that played animal crackers in episode
5s Murder House bonus points if you
caught the fly in the bottom-left
the kid stares at what appears to be a
dot were across once hung before falling
into Ruth's bed at the psychiatry clinic
the doctor asks Ruth to do an Alzheimer
screening test just like what Henry and
the kid did in episode 5 unlike them
however it doesn't seem like she can
remember the words Allen tells Ruth he
has some business to take care of but
when he gets back he's going to fix her
all up inside the home Ruth opens her
Louis chess set the same one she got
from Allen in episode 5 the red and
crimson colors not only act as a
metaphor for good and evil but they're
also the colors the kid and Henry were
given in their psychiatric tests
historians argue that
the Lewis chess pieces were not
originally black and white rather stains
found on the originals indicated they
were red and white
Ruth takes out a queen and a rook who
holds a spear henry picks up his son
Wendell who seems to be more preoccupied
with his video game than with seeing his
dad hinting at a strange relationship
Wendell takes Henry's old room where
there's two subtle references to the
devil one the Tasmanian Devil bed sheets
and two Grant Fuhr the hockey player who
played for the Calgary Flames flames
which are apparently still overtaking
the surrounding area Henry takes Wendell
to see Ruth who both starts and ends the
scene staring at something in the corner
we know from previous shots that this is
either the mirror or bed a bet a few
scenes ago we saw the kid layin is she
seeing something we aren't Molly gets a
call from a potential buyer when she's
interrupted by the bandage man we saw
from episode three she takes a pill and
writes in her notepad and what appears
to be a log of her drug use you can see
the date the word OC likely oxycontin
and dosage five milligrams 10 milligrams
but notice all the dates say 2017 I'm
not sure why this is the case because
we're supposed to be in 2018 and here
she is giving us the finger but that's
probably just a coincidence Wendell
reads the program for his grandfather's
funeral where you can make it the quote
from Corinthians Ruth holds a chess
piece by the fridge harkening back to
episode 2 where henry found the same
piece looking out the window Ruth sees
the kid and says I could have sworn we
buried him in that suit now her memory
is pretty shot so we can't take
everything she says at face value
however with the casket being moved
twice Allen's penchant for digging up
Graves and the fact we've never seen the
body is it possible someone opened the
casket
Henry retrieves the kid from the side
house where he finds him watching old
VHS tapes Mathew refers to young Henry
as Evel Knievel a daredevil in the
volcano Krakatoa one of the most violent
volcanic events in recorded history -
odd references to the devil and flames
we hear Mathew say which way do you
think it is son which is likely
referring to the sound or as will later
find it called the skismo
Henry and the kid arrived at juniper
Hill a psychiatric hospital featured in
such books
it insomnia and bag of bones as the kid
has taken in a crow smashes into the
ground killing itself traditionally
crows and ravens have been omens of bad
luck and death in other cultures they've
been a sign of mystery and destiny but
considering the fate of this one it's
probably the former Henry apologizes to
Wendell about having to leave when
Wendell presses him about his upbringing
Henry was adopted at age five after the
Devers tried to have a baby but it died
in labor Wendell asks about Henry's real
parents but Henry skirts the question is
it possible when Henry burned the VHS
tape and said Fu dad that it was
referring to his biological father
Henry then asked Ruth what he and his
dad did in the woods
she says camping and hunting but when he
asked her about if he ever mentioned a
sound she feigns ignorance out by the
woods Henry's flashbacks intensify in
one of the biggest scenes of the episode
Henry asked Molly if she ever saw him go
out in the woods at weird hours of the
night she tells him that she could feel
how he hated his father was afraid then
suddenly relieved she can't tell him
what actually happened that night only
what he felt and that he wanted his dad
dead she confesses that she was the one
who killed Matthew by taking out his
breathing tube but that she wasn't in
control
it was Henry controlling her when I
looked down at my hand it was like it
was your hand we killed him together
Henry calls her crazy and marches off
Pangborn breaks into a junkyard likely
in syracuse where he was told to go buy
the kid in this scene between Wendell
and Ruth we learned the importance of
the chess pieces she apparently slips
between past and present and the pieces
help ground her in reality somewhat like
the totems in Christopher Nolan's
inception Henry uses the camcorder to
retrace his steps as a kid that is until
it runs out of battery Pangborn retreats
back to his truck after turning up
empty-handed when we hear on the radio
that eight staff and six patients have
died in a fire at juniper Hill
not to mention four patient's considered
dangerous have escaped but Pangburn
rushes from his car when he sees Dale
Lacey's crushed Lincoln pull in in fact
he's so desperate to get this car that
he holds the truck driver at gunpoint to
get it Ruth drops her pills and watches
as the kid who's supposed to be a
Juniper Hill but likely escaped walk in
notice
he takes off his shoes remember in
Episode four have Ruth chastises Henry
about how his father wouldn't abide by
any click clocks in the house there's
mounting evidence that the kid is
somehow connected to Ruth and Matthew
Henry stumbles upon the two creepy dudes
who will come to learn our young Willy
and Odin branch Odin branch being a
weird name considering Odin the Norse
God hung himself by a tree branch as a
form of sacrifice the idea of
sacrificing oneself to gain something
like what Odin did is echoed later on by
branch young Willie on the other hand
acts as Odin's interpreter and Protege
Odin tells Henry that he knew his father
that he considered this his church out
here just like in Episode two when the
pastor says day Lacey's church was the
forest they've made their way here for
two reasons to listen and to correct
young Willie whatever this correction is
you can tell by young Willie's face that
it probably won't be comfortable and it
may or may not involve a hot poker The
Listening on the other hand is a
reference to the skismo or as Henry's
father called it some people never hear
it some people hear at once and for some
it's deafening apparently his father
could hear it then lost it perhaps why
he adopted Henry because he knew he
could hear it and was using him the
skismo is also referred to as the music
of the spheres an ancient philosophical
concept that regards proportions in the
movements of celestial bodies the Sun
Moon and planets as a form of music
music of the spheres was also the title
chosen for the musical foundation of the
video game destiny which when Henry
asked Wendell what he's playing he says
what sounds like thief of destiny
coincidence the connection with
astronomy can be seen in the paintings
behind the doctor's office the flashback
Henry sees later on and how Wendell
wanted to be an astronaut growing up
skismo according to Odin is the sound of
the universe trying to reconcile all the
possible paths and presence just like
how Ruth is trying to reconcile her past
and present but the sound of the
universe is getting louder likely why
the ringing in Henry's ear has been
getting worse and since olden told him
that they haven't heard it this loud in
decades it's starting to make more sense
why Henry last experienced at this bad
when he was a teenager
apparently Henry's father was building
something a filter to drown out all the
unwanted noise so that he could listen
to the voice of God now I have a crazy
theory which I think is gonna get a lot
of flack but hear me out on it could out
and be Henry's biological father now
hear me out okay that's a terrible pun
considering Odin is deaf but here's what
we know
Mathew and Odin knew each other and they
knew each other well meeting in the
force for likely years and gaining each
other's trust Odin tells Henry that
Mathew conceived of a device but he
never got the chance to build it like
his child who was conceived but died in
labor
then Odin goes on to say fortunately I
did followed by a weird exchange of
glances
we also know Oh Dan has the ability to
hear the skismo
on a powerful level just like Henry
perhaps he chose to give up his child
because he needed to continue his work
believing it to be more important kind
of like how Henry puts his work before
his own son Matthew who didn't have a
child than having lost his ability to
hear the skismo adopted Odin's child as
it was mutually beneficial for both of
them we also know that Odin takes on a
protege in a master apprentice type of
dynamic could Matthew in Odin's
relationship have been like that or de
Lacey for that matter
Odin beckons Henry to the RV so like any
rational person finding two strangers in
the forest Henry agrees to get inside
Odin introduces him to the anechoic
chamber which is used to drown out
excess noise leaving only the skismo and
convinces him to get inside telling him
that what he'll hear and there is the
truth that he may find what kind of man
he is why he really came home as Henry
gets inside
Odin tells him he only hears the skismo
now after correcting himself to which
Henry replies you made yourself deaf
Knight Odin locks Henry in the chamber
where he experiences his most extreme
flashbacks yet sounds of the woods his
father saying do you hear it now
multiple images of the car and Sam from
Episode five a finger with a ring and
blood on it as if someone is cutting a
wrist with a piece of glass the face of
the kid both in a picture that mimics
those from the psych lab and found
footage bars young Henry wearing glasses
a man with the cane and shots of Henry
running through the woods similar to
those seen in episode three Allen
arrives back with the deed to warden
Lacey's car and tells the kid it should
be there tomorrow morning but something
isn't quite right the kid is bleeding or
at least it's shot to look like it's his
blood and he gives Allen a cryptic
message saying there will be a monument
to warden Lacey and everyone who put me
in that cage now monuments are usually
used to commemorate someone or something
but in the biblical days the word
monument meant tomb or grave the kid
finishes by saying why would you leave
me in that trunk sheriff a throwback to
when Allen let Dale Lacey Drive off with
a kid
Allen rushes in search of Ruth to find
the house torn apart blood splattered on
the floor
or in walls implying the kid did
something but I don't believe that to be
the case there are a few possible
answers here
one Routh not having taken her pills and
becoming increasingly frightened of the
kid did this to herself remember we've
seen her do some irrational things too
it could be the other escaped inmates
from juniper Hill 3 remember what
Molly's house look like in episode 3
could this be the same thing now
plaguing the Devers also where is
Wendell this episode started to reveal a
bit more about what Henry's father was
doing in the forest and the greater
mystery surrounding Castle Rock with
only four episodes left I think it's
really gonna start ramping up thank you
for watching as always if you enjoyed
this video make sure to LIKE and
subscribe
I am super pumped because Castle Rock
has been renewed for season two I'm also
looking for suggestions on other series
to do so leave your suggestions and
castle rock theories below until next
week